i think it's pretty amazing that people
are
[Music]
um
bringing light to
the
the homelessness the streets you know
the story is acknowledged and
all these others no
lives and
veins
intertwining going people
yeah exactly
you just had rougher childhoods
yeah than the rest of most of us i think
right
all right randy where'd you grow up
where are you from where is it i'm from
um boy heights is los angeles
tell me about your family your parents
um my mom's from whitefins she's colleen
from iphones my dad's from city terror
sunny from city terrace
so both your parents were gang members
yeah well east side bay i'm a east side
baby you know we're from the east side
um
my mother passed away
when i was about five months
you know old
gonna put a wire shield
fighting another
another person another [ __ ] or another
woman and um
she
that woman took out a knife and um
stabbed my mother a few times and my
mother passed away from internal
bleeding how old were you i was
about five five months old five six
months old oh yeah yeah
so the day she was doing her peacocks
she
put her um curling iron on the
on the
the dressing cabinet and it acts it fell
and burned me on my leg
on my um my left uh
my left leg
so they call
they nickname it curly you know
i have credit here but they named curtis
for a
spot right here
um
you know i just
throughout the years you know after um
after exceeding all my life you know
my
elder homies nicknamed me uh raider
for uh
i'm more like a raider uh
curly yeah i mean you know
just uh one of the three stooges right
you know just to just to reflect that i
was a
you know so you're almost destined to be
a gang member with both your parents and
gangs yeah i have los angeles gang
member my neck on the right side of my
neck
with the [ __ ] the system on my side boy
heights mcf
um you finished high school
um no
i went to 11th i played high school
football though i played for roosevelt
high school
um
i was i was pretty good but
i was i was motivated to go to the
i kept uh i got
i first got incarcerated for assault oh
no it was a illegal weapon on school
grounds
as a knife so i went to juvenile hall
got out
a few months went back to camp
for a burglary i went up to right to
passage and it's it's a boot camp in
europe nevada
and um they send this the third third uh
hardest boot camp in uh the nation
and um
i was there
for two years
and uh it's it's it's placement but it's
boot camp you know
and um
it's
uh i hate i liked it and i hated it
because
it's a frustrating um
frustrating you know always getting
[ __ ] with but
you know so you joined the gang what age
i do this yeah i was already from uh my
neighborhood when when you get involved
in that though um
13 13. yeah did you feel like there was
a choice or was just it's just oh you
know
it was it was it was it was
i was torn between getting into wipings
which is very traditional and um
yeah very traditional so i i wanted to
be from white fans but
yet again
for my neighborhood that was really
pretty much active
um
wife is a it has long tradition but
they're pretty much um
uh
at the time they're thin now you know
everyone was busted no one's really on
the block i want to be like colors like
30 homeboys on the block you know
selling those walking down everything
just you know i wanted to feel that
energy you know so
mc force was um
and see force was uh
that was a
that was my my um
you know so me my cup my twin cousins
and my best owned by a boxer we all
oh yeah my cousin trustee and gothel and
trigger we all got in the neighborhood i
was five six seven eight eight of us
and i got into my neighborhood in 1990
december of 1993.
so
where you guys all now
oh man so
so
uh my cousins sean killed
their own brother
on accident you know
um i think he was just spun out on drugs
over
um
they're both doing life um for murder
uh
my my cousin speedy's murder for hire
um and um
my cousin smurfs
shot kills his brother eddie
so you're lucky to be alive
yeah and then free my cousin trustee was
assassinated by accident mistaken
identity
uh that caused uh sympathy metaphase too
um i'm sorry for moving
that caused sympathy metaphase for
to start going at it
and that war has been current now for
about seven years now
what attracts a young man to that life
even before all your friends
gotten
into it well in east delay we have
tagging crews we have party crews so
before i got into a gang i was i was
rolling around with the
the party crews of you know chronic and
you know hip-hop society uh
mom my tagging crew was cks cks city
king styles it's a big game a big
big tank crew back in 92 93 you know
east l.a
but all those guys generated into gangs
different clicks from neighborhoods and
i drifted off to myself
and um but you were aware that it's
either prison or death right yeah i mean
even even when you joined the gang of 13
you probably knew it was prison or death
right at that age i wasn't even thinking
about jail at all i wasn't even thinking
about nothing really nobody said
anything to you yeah just just
i just want to feel
accepted by um
by my peers but i accepted my by my
community acknowledged that i was
doing somehow some way
protecting my streets you know the
the senoras the
friends you know that was
you know you know a watchful life or
for them you know
if
any harm came their way or any problems
or anything you know anyone stealing
their stuff or anything because my
grandmother was um
she was per snatch
you know
so i mean
you know so my my grandmother rosemary
gill she she did all she can to raise me
you know but
i still
i still was all
you know you know in and out of jail so
how much prison time have you done
well
i went to
well when i was after after rites of
passage
i committed another offense oh yeah i
got down with an enemy in school
um from vicky's town
and
i went to jail for um oh the cops came
started roughing me up so i ended up
catching uh assault on a police officer
on um in high school
and um went to jail
went back to camp to uh i went to camp
men
i went to camp gonzalez and then i went
to mendenhall i got revived from
mendenhall and went to miller and went
home and in total your whole life how
much how many years have you done
man
close up to 20 21 20 23 years 23 years
yeah because i after that i caught i saw
the firearm
and a strong arm robbery
on soto and with her
and um for the you know for them higher
gentlemen
and uh i just probably more than half of
your life in prison yeah i got six years
with two strikes
so after i got out 2006
i was shot seven times um
fighting with my enemies
um
yeah i have the scar right here
this is a pretty
pronounced car
wow
so
it's a serious car yeah flat line i
flatline on the table twice
so i kind of um
kind of got a glimpse of uh
eternity and you know the good and the
bad you know
and um it woke me up too
well
it's not just life that it was a greater
it's a higher cr higher uh
higher um
higher being my my higher um
you saw that when you were on the table
yeah i flatlined twice but
tell me a little bit about that
when i um
the doctor said i'll i'm gonna do
everything i can to save your life so i
went into surgery for nine hours
so in the field they sewed the female
artery up
and um during that flatline for nine
seconds the second was for four
thank god my heart was strong enough to
revive itself
and um
uh i felt
as if uh
like
it was it was it was all colors it was
all colors
and
it was like a power
a love
that you could feel
i felt like if i was missed i wasn't
even in human form i felt like if i was
a
just just uh
just a missed
it but all together
and um
i felt
just a love
passing not not just like that i could
feel a sense
but it was
as if it was passing through me
like through eternity like going going
past you going
you know past
past your ancestors past you down to you
down to your
offspring everything i felt
and then all of a sudden i
the gloom
went away
and all darkness
all darkness came
and it felt it felt
i immediately felt
like the the
darkness
was alive and wanted to
to
hate it it just hated you it just wanted
to
hurt you just wanted to get you and
destroy you and i i was afraid you know
first time i was like i'm not really
afraid of nothing but
that
it got me like
acknowledged you know acknowledge that
that is you know
i guess it was god telling me like hey
i'm i'm here but
if you walk without me this is what
you're
walking with so
i am
i still
didn't take heed
still got out the hospital i woke up on
christmas day with cookies in there so
so
that was in 2006
2007 aid i was
i was a riot but i started catching uh
pro violations
i caught up able violation
nine month violation 10 more violations
then i did a year in chino
then um
i mean
i was all right i was already embedded
into politics but that's when um
i really started
getting my name out there running county
jails running prisons running
yards or
organizing stuff just
just i guess being on
keeping the eye of of
of um
not doing our own people
unjust
keeping an eye on uh prosperity respect
and and uh unity amongst
the ranks of all of us this uh the
school you know
and i said i mean
in prison it's a little more racial
where it's the mexicans against the
blacks against the whites yeah i've been
in riots with them
but where people die you know where
people die
and um
i've known friends that that have you
know never made it so
they are very dangerous you know i
um i was in the the right at cmc
um not a couple years ago with a
with a
my big homie there you know in the yard
so
and i'm on the master so i'm
representing you know so
i've been there i've been there and i
know how uh
so
i mean
me and my family were just uh
we were kind of entwined you know i have
a
but um
after uh
after prison after i
after getting out
of those violations i stood out for
about
a year or two
and ended up um
catching a assault with a deadly weapon
i boss cutter i
hit some fool in the face with a boss
cutter sliced him
through his cheek
bridge uh under underneath his eye and
threw a bridge of his nose
for uh
he jumped my girlfriend along with a
couple of his homeboys from you know
and his homegirls because she didn't
want to get down with my my lady
so
that led to me
uh showing aggression and then know who
who i was
and that cost me um
seven years of my life i was lucky it
didn't cost me my whole life but
when um
i didn't even know that i was uh that he
had filed a report
so
those those couple days i
i was on drugs somewhere in hollywood
mom one of my home girls didn't want to
charge my phone she was acting stupid
you know i think it was hollywood and
and western yeah where the rouse is i
ended up breaking them
having a i guess i'll say a mental
a mental outburst breakdown or whatever
i end up breaking the windows both
windows to ralphs
and uh waited till the cops got there
and there's an employee there that try
to get involved try to stop me whatever
she said i threatened her which was that
was not the case
even though i summoned we summoned the
the video and showed
it showed that uh
i was i was following truth with my word
you know like she said i hit the window
20 times which was i broke the window
once
what drug were you on oh i was on meth i
was on meth and um
no sleep you know so that's a bad news
no more no water no nothing no
not nurse but
so
i um yeah i i got incarcerated
i went um so
in prison do you do you get into other
activities too yeah i mean i i went to
i've been writing i went pro-pr you know
i went to after fighting it and in the
english court i got bonded over well so
i didn't know i was i was getting uh
i didn't know i was getting um
followed by uh i didn't know i had a
warrant out from
linux sheriff
and um
the woman the detective she ended up
being born and raised in my neighborhood
so knew a lot about my neighborhood
and um
you know reminiscing
oh you guys shot didn't you guys shoot
that little kid i'm like no no no we
don't do that you know we don't
that was the other neighbor that that
shot
at us and ended up killing a kid you
know
kid you know
in a killing on my humble champ's little
niece
and my own boy's little girl
and so um
that's probably a lot of violence
so when people were to get in my
neighborhood that would be the first
neighborhood they'll hit
you know it's just evergreen you know
which was uh
there to the left of us
so it's wi-fi's evergreen us then cam
hazard
and
so that's like
the little role right there in these
i know it's interesting it's all one
city but there's they're all worries
right yeah very much you know
uh brief streets right there tiny boys
right there big metal flats right there
east delays right there so it's we all
don't get along
we all hate each other so these are all
mexican gangs yes very very strong very
powerful they hit each other yeah i
don't know and then it's not even about
a black or white thing or mexican yeah
yeah it's this uh it's a whole nother
set of it's a whole nother form of hate
that you have to uh
it causes it causes you if you're
walking down the street to glance back
to check the corner to
see see the people on the streets
see what their whole uh check their
hands see with their friends and see
their
evaluate their body expressions if
they're
that they have if they're following you
looking at you
um
[Music]
trying to
keep tabs on
um
you know just
see if you know two blocks down so you
know see they're still
so i got to his life more treacherous in
prison or in on the streets
[Music]
i will stay on the streets because a lot
more worse could happen to you
um
and the streets of caesar
you get stabbed to death in your cell or
you get stabbed on the yard
you might live through it
or a riot or you know fight
out here
you have automatic weapons you have uh
people that know how to shoot you know
yeah well
i've been on a lot of shootouts you know
i have a multi gun charges um one on
brandishing a firearm on lapd
you know i fought that case for nine
months and and um they didn't have no
firearms so
i took a child twice and
and uh the d.a dismissed the case
you know so that was with the
two uh
two
false imprisonments that were there
they're my people they let me in the
house so
i had
they manipulated
my people to um roll over on me which i
take no offense because
uh once my homegirl was my homeboy they
didn't they couldn't suffer uh coming
into contact with the law one didn't
have papers and the other one
had warrants and wasn't ready to go to
jail because she had she had just had a
kid
so but
they twisted my words whatever just
their words but i still managed to um
beat the case but but when you're in
prison do you get orders to do things
that uh
off iran
i ran
around lancaster
chino
um
law school
law school with the
first generation metski mafia
and um
and right now cmc
with the
first generation and and
it's different if you have a
passport with uh just a hand-me-down
license
other than them being there
next to you giving you
the the opportunity to um
to um
run the show for them you know and in
steps in good faith that
it's it's all you know
of resemblance of of of their
their um
their style you know their their style
their image
so i i got that on
i got the
to take a that deep breath and uh
and um succeed in that successfully you
know yeah but i'm talking about like
with with sex of like oh sexy i stepped
i stabbed a rapist
nine times sent him to the hospital in
delano that was my first time you know
so you'll get orders to do that kind of
stuff
yeah sex offenders we don't tolerate you
know um
members of my family were victimized
from from that uh that evil so uh how
does that happen in prison somebody just
comes to you and say here's what you're
doing to today um
um
there's a there's a way of
i'm fascinated we we express like hey
look at
yeah
there's a there's this dude on the yard
there's a dude right here that
he raped uh
like the dude i stabbed he raped a
six-year-old girl with a cro with a
chrono with a
foreign object with a corona bottle so i
stabbed him nine times
without question the next day i came out
and i stabbed him nine times and i hit
him with the
the thick trays the state trays
and um split his uh
his head there
and um
and caught a a battery and a seal for
trying to protect the child molester i
took offense to that too so i got off on
the police for trying to
protect them so i caught on two charges
that day two day referrals
or so thank god that they were not
acknowledged
because at the time sometimes on
the d will
look the other way because it's because
it's a sex offender right you know it's
just
you know depending what da though you
know
but most days though
they know what time it is you know it's
going to happen anyways
but it's inevitable but you've been out
now for how long
uh i've barely been out for not even 80
days
are you fresh out fresh out from doing
seven
from the gbi and where are you staying
now um north hollywood trying to get
into housing you're oh you're in the
street now yeah
um trying to trying to get into housing
so um
um
i have a i'm a i'm native american with
a bi number
and now i'm commercial real estate 20
acres of communities commercial real
estate in scottsdale arizona
i bury my grandmother and sells arizona
because she's uh she's papagol and my
grandfather's pima and them two tribes
uh joined each other to make touhou no
ham
so
we have uh we're
we're one of the largest uh
indian uh native soils uh in the united
states
uh we speak the the native the native uh
uh youtube
youtube uh aztec language there's 22
different dialects and we speak on
but um
um my tribe endured a lot
from mexico and
uh
the the calvary you know the u.s so
we we endured we um
most of them were scouts and i guess uh
you know my
it's just uh just the reconnaissance uh
i guess it runs in my blood because
my um my tribes were
scalped for the u.s calvary
you know on
um
the mexican troops started fighting
though
the northern regiment
and um
my grand
my grandfather was an army ranger
but died in normandy died
and d-day he's buried in a military
cemetery
my father's uh air force reconnaissance
my uncle's
marine uh um
united states marines uh forced recon
i joined the marines at 18 but 30 days
into enlistment i caught that fire
assault with the firearm and
and uh
robbery stronghold robbery
so
30 more days i was already i took the
asbab test i was ready to go so that up
that broke my spirit but
i i guess i belong to the street
military i guess you know street
platinum children of your own
uh i have two daughters you do yeah my
daughter sunshine and
my daughter aber abigail
so
i mean
i never met my second daughter
miss baker and she lives in bakersfield
my second bay mom
i mean
while i was there with her she wasn't
pregnant but all of a sudden she moves
up there and oh i gotta but i don't care
if if it is mine i want everything to do
with my daughter
um my first daughter i have good uh
good time good relations with
mom
unfortunately she's not with her mom
she's a
she's saying my my cousin desiree got
custody of her
but um
she gives her anything she wants and
everything
and but me about the drug use now that
you're out are you using it again well
yeah because i mean
my
my big mama's uh
second
baby daddy
molested my daughter for two years and
was uh
arrested for and everything but
not
dealt with on the street yet you know so
getting out just knowing all that
was uh that's hard to live with yeah
it's hard to knowing this is what i do
you know see seek and retrieve um
uh those child molesters that are
that are alert
keeping up their negative evil behavior
their their awful
you know staying around parks schools
if we see this in the community
which i have a strong eye for
and since
then i immediately
you know
react and go about
you know
necessary steps to get them away
or and
that
pyro their tents whatever
hunt them down beat them up
um
or just you know
uh let them know that there's a presence
that's strong on them that's that will
that will
you know
let uh
they will they will get their hands
you know they do have a long reach so
they could you could they could stick
around if they want or they could they
could flee you know
unless it was so is your dad still
around my dad oh man my dad
he was the best dad i've ever had he put
me in every damn
soccer football baseball
basketball karate gymnastics everything
and um
i still
i had a bad habit before uh smoking rock
cocaine
just before meth was you know popping
so
um
that and
you know
some dude passed by as my enemies passed
by she shot with the little i was with
my two friends
two on boxer from wife and cisco for
white fans and there's me on four string
grand vista with his wife and
evergreen passed by and shot with a
little 22.
i got mad pull out my beretta
and let him up
and then up uh
i guess the neighbor got
afraid
told my dad and my dad all
distance himself for me i guess because
i was getting too reckless with myself
with um
putting people in jeopardy i guess you
know um
hurting him you know it hurt me just the
worst thing
it's the it's the worst hate that i've
ever felt in my life it's just knowing
that
that i failed him and couldn't
rejuvenate and
couldn't show him that uh
i couldn't make it out to him
in any any any kind of way
so
that's
that's always going to be a hole in my
heart you know because usual is a
wonderful good father
what's your biggest regret in your life
uh i will say that hurting my dad and
my grandmother you know before she
passed away in 95.
do you regret taking the path that your
life took with gangs and all that
or you just feel like that's just
i
i can't because i met so many good
people along the way so i i feel
that god has um
unfolded
a path for me to to walk in
and
i guess he entwines us he he allows us
to meet
other people for a reason
for reasons for that are greater than
us you know
and
just
don't understand i i regret just not
not you know i'm not
getting to know god first you know
you know just not not being
not praying to her not waking up my eyes
now opening my eyes and say thank you
lord for allowing this
you know sometimes i tend to forget
every day or every other day
like you know but
those days when i do
uh
want to know the lord and and talk to
him express and
pray
and fear him
things things um
things uh
things feel better things seem better
and i also felt
uh i've also been on that
on that iceberg with uh
with the all the hatred and now the evil
and demons and
all those
you know i've seen
i worked inside of a freeway before
and my duty was to
protect uh protect uh the customers and
make sure there's no extreme violence
no rapes no no sex depends no uh
domestic minimum
no guns you know
and um
you know i've seen people oh dee i've
seen people
die i've seen people buried i've seen
people shot i've seen people stab
i've done the same
and um
i still managed to uh
to bring on
to make the group whatever group that's
there at the time getting high or
whatever
comfortable and safe
and
for some reason it it means something to
me
that
things could be a lot different you know
with someone else there
but someone that gets the right
heart mind prosperity in his in his
heart
to care for another human being other
than yourself
there's not too many people
around him
around like that no more
so
you know i just
pretty much got uh
pretty much got adopted by
you know some masons you know
and got to know
and gotta uh turn another leaf over
other than just the south side regiment
you know just
see uh
see all
life and all aspects through a different
mirror and different view
and it was pretty interesting you know
pretty interesting
you know
i felt
you know
with just cause you know like like
someone could just
i can't just go walk down the street and
hurt somebody for no reason like i used
to it would have to be for
a just cause you know i i absolutely
have to be for reason you know
so
i just saw
you know but people still somehow some
somehow some way stumbled upon
my back
so uh
you know but randy what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
um
i'm always very hard on myself but uh
most important life thing in life is to
to really know what you want to really
if i would have known what i've known
younger
i would have been right
but
18 years old or gun blazing wanting to
get your name out there
having people
you know
i really didn't care about people
fearing me but
yeah my my name was pretty
you know from
all the shootouts and all the
other you know chasing foot down and
honey
as as a
i was pretty intense i was pretty
i was if you had me in the back seat is
on you know i said
uh my homies love me you know
you know
not just that i was digesting
uh
knowledge of of of
and
taking uh photographic memories of
of uh
political situations and how to unravel
knots and how to digest
whatever's going on how to put in
compartments or dissident having to
analyze
and and dissect
a critical situation that might
all right
these guys are moving forward rapidly oh
they're another race okay this is how we
do it
you know we don't underestimate nobody
but
we do have to um
i have to i have to make sure my people
is safe and make sure
there's a
there's a force protecting them you know
so
it just means a lot to me you know but
yeah i if i die for it then i'll be
happy you know cause
i'm not just dying for myself
no
done for something that's uh
should be uh
should be recognized you
know should be recognized
people do so it's kind of hard to
represent a cause
that uh we live by the court of silence
a lot of people don't know gangbanging
they don't know nothing really
on how many uh how sophisticated and how
whether
you know elements we
we have to endure and go through and
sort out is this uh
this uh
they have no clue they just think we're
at
animals without thought you know but
it's really
it's really family and
you know
fun you know it's fun you know but
you know
i don't know man they also know me as
r2d2
get a robot so
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story all right take care man wish
you the
best thanks
you